ukraine's zaparisha nuclear power plant
which is held by russian forces remains
disconnected from the energy grid
causing blackouts across the region
the plant was knocked offline on
thursday due to shelling but has managed
to restore its own power
that means its cooling and safety
systems are still functional but
ukraine's president vladimir zolensky
says the world has narrowly avoided a
radiation disaster
before russia's invasion the vast
zaparisia nuclear plant supplied around
20 percent of ukraine's energy needs but
on thursday it was temporarily cut off
from the country's power grid entirely
after fires visible here on satellite
imagery knocked out its last external
power line
that forced the facility's last two
operating reactors to shut down
ukrainian officials say power has since
been restored
one reactor is back online and work is
reportedly underway to restore the other
russian forces have been in control of
the plant since march and ukraine has
blamed them for starting the fires but
russia claims they were sparked by
ukrainian shelling
for weeks now increased fighting of the
plant has raised fears of a nuclear
catastrophe
experts fear that a loss of power would
leave the facility forced to rely on
emergency backup generators to cool its
reactors
the diesel generators didn't turn on
if after the blackout the automatic
systems and the personnel didn't start
working
we would have to face the consequences
of a radiation accident
russia has put ukrainians as well as all
europeans one step away from radiation
disaster
catastrophe
the head of the un's nuclear watchdog
told french broadcaster france24 he's
planning to visit
i think now there is a general
recognition
that we need to be there we need to be
there soon
kiev
accepts it
moscow accepts it we need to go and we
are going to be there hopefully very
very soon
the un and world leaders have called for
the creation of a demilitarized zone
surrounding the plant to avert disaster
but russia has rejected that proposal
well for the latest i'm joined now by dw
correspondent roman gonciarenko in kiev
hello to you roman so tell us what is
the situation right now at the zappos
nuclear power plant
well the situation there remains very
volatile and it is not quite clear what
exactly is happening
um we had reports that the power station
was reconnected with the ukrainian power
grid after it was cut off for the first
time in its history
there were reports in ukrainian media
that one of the reactors was running
again then there was other reports that
both reactors are still shut down
and it is not quite clear if they will
um uh reconnect both of them during the
day probably yes uh this is what we
expect so uh this whole situation we had
some also a confirmation from satellite
images that there is a fire in a forest
nearby
which according to both sides the
russian and the ukrainian side caused
that cut off yesterday
so uh to clear the situation uh it shows
that the
delegation of the international atomic
agency
should go there it is being discussed it
is expected in the coming days but it's
still it is still not clear which route
they would take
through ukraine which is what kiev
insists on or through russia which kiev
says is not possible and um is against
it so we do not have that an answer to
that most important question which route
the the delegation of the international
experts would take to visit the station
but we can assume that that visit will
happen in the coming days
now do we have any information on
whether thursday's power cut in some way
affected the safety of the nuclear plant
in any way
well the ukrainian authorities are
saying that no
there was
everything was under control at that
time so we have ukrainian personnel on
that station you have to remember and
russian soldiers
there
and a lot of russian military equipment
according to the ukrainian sources
but the station itself the reactors
they remain intact according to the
ukrainian sources and the
security mechanisms worked as they are
supposed to do this is what we know from
the ukrainian side
that was dw's roman goncharenko
reporting for us from kiev roman thank
you
well now we can bring in vadim chumach
he's from ukraine's national research
center for radiation medicine and he's
also in kiev welcome to dw
um vadim we're just getting reports now
that the nuclear power plant in zapatia
is still disconnected from the
electricity grid
can you just explain to us why this is
dangerous
uh so well actually uh the nuclear
reactors when they are operating they're
uh accumulating enormous amount of
short-lived red nuclei decay products
uh which are quite hot not only in the
sense of radiation but also in
colloquial terms of temperature
so when a reactor is
stopped it should be cooled for a couple
of months further to
bring temperatures down
and it's impossible without electricity
so if there is no external power lines
then diesel generators need to to be
started and
such systems are in place and they
should should run uh but still so the
the resource of their operation is quite
limited it's a couple of weeks only
uh but this cooling down will take
months or more
uh so there is a big danger of
an accident
of fukushima type
and now do you think a visit by the
international atomic energy agency would
somehow make a real difference i mean
what could those inspectors or those
officials do to make things safer
well so they cannot solve all problems
of course
but at least to my opinion they can
leash
russian authorities because without any
control so
so they behave
absolutely ruthlessly and uh
irresponsible so if some
international mission will be on the
spot uh both possibly they will be
limited in their varied actions
that was vadim chumach from ukraine's
national research center for radiation
medicine thank you so much
you're welcome
russia has confirmed that it hit a
railway station on ukraine's
independence day ukraine says the
missile strike on the eastern town of
chaplina also hit a residential area
it says at least 25 people were killed
and dozens more injured russia claims it
targeted a military train and that more
than 200 ukrainian troops died in that
attack
chaplina in eastern ukraine
it's the latest town to become
synonymous with grief and terror
the train station is now quiet but the
bombing is all too clear
in residents minds
i heard the explosions there was a loud
bomb
when i drove by i saw four people lying
on the ground two of them very close two
further away then the police came to
cover their bodies
the strike targeted a train stationed in
chaplina
witnesses say some of the victims burned
to death in train carriages
the town too
got its share of the destruction
when the explosion happened we were
standing here we were blown to the
ground we stood between the walls the
wave of the blast blew everything out
russia's defense ministry says the train
was carrying arms to ukrainian front
lines in the donbas region
ukrainian officials did not say how many
of those killed were civilians
the attack is one of the deadliest in
the country in weeks
for some of the residents here it will
leave permanent scars as they count
their losses of homes neighbors
and loved ones
ndw correspondent dion philip schultz
joins us now from chaplina
so uh tell us what more have you learned
about the attack there
chaplin was a very small quiet town in a
remote area of the
nipro region and this all changed
overnight when the russian missiles hit
the place here almost everybody here in
the small town knows somebody who was
affected actually a lot of people are on
the way to a funeral of a small boy at
the moment there's this is especially
tragic story of a father who found the
dead body of his son during a search and
rescue mission
we don't know all the details what has
happened here we know a train was hit
very close to the train station and some
residential buildings were hit as well
you can see some of them
behind me we don't know if it was a
normal passenger train or if it had some
kind of military
purpose it is completely burned out so
it's impossible to say but what we know
is that the russians were obviously
completely indifferent to civilian
casualties at least 25 people died in
the attack and
the claim that 200 soldiers 200
ukrainian soldiers died in the strike is
also false
this region here nepal region seems to
be in the focus of attacks at the moment
we received reports this morning that
nine other places in the regions have
been hit in the past hours but
fortunately no further civilian
casualties
dw's dan philip schultz reporting for us
thank you so much
you